I've never censored what I say I've
always put it all out there good for you
yeah I've done that all my life but do
you don't you find that it's more not
just accepted but people are more
interested in it now because of the
internet yeah for sure yeah absolutely
because I've heard about you for many
many years but it's sort of ramped up
over the last you know decade or so
right yeah because of the internet right
because people have this but you know
I've been around it's funny when I look
at this stuff like you know all the
stuff about pot and it's like no eggsy
beause I was saying this stuff in the
1970s you know my first book the natural
mind was published in 1972 it argued
that everybody has an innate drive to
alter their consciousness yeah and you
know drugs are one way of doing it I did
the first human experiments with pot
that were ever done with under
double-blind conditions what experiments
did you do
I gave marijuana to people in a
laboratory in 1968 and would you test
them for well we were just seeing people
bet me you couldn't do it nobody had
ever done this you know that all this
marijuana was becoming such a big thing
and nobody there were no experiments
like what what what kind of experiments
so I took like I'm the most basic stuff
I just wanted to show that you could
give it to human subjects in a lab and
get away with it because people thought
you wouldn't you know you mean in terms
of the FTC in terms of law lawsuits
everybody you know one of the things I
wanted to give it to people that never
had it before to speak so there'd be no
expectations everyone said this is
terrible you know they're gonna turn it
to heroin addicts from giving them stuff
like that anyway I just wanted to see
basic stuff like does it dilate the
pupils of the eyes because cops were
busting people you know they'd say their
eyes are dilated yeah must be high in
marijuana and they'd search but
marijuana doesn't we showed doesn't
violate the pupils of the eyes
I took a chat tested blood sugar because
people said the reason people get hungry
is because blood sugar drops has no
effect on blood sugar we showed that you
know people who had never had marijuana
before in a lab you could show slight
decreases in performance and motor
function and cognitive function but
people who were regular users of it you
couldn't show that that they had adapted
to it yeah my take on that is that
I think the people that are not regular
users are freaking out yeah and because
they're not all sensations and then I'll
do it yeah and they just don't they
don't know how to relax
right yeah I mean that's it's the big
one to me with with physical movement
young they want to you know test drivers
and also Jennings for marijuana I'm like
this is not alcohol you're talking about
a completely different thing if I had a
choice of being a passenger with these
drivers I'll tell you which one I would
take a person who had never used
marijuana had just smoked a person who
was a user of marijuana and it just
smoked but it never driven high a person
who was a user regular using marijuana
and at practice driving high and a
person with any amount of alcohol in
their system I take the third as the
best bet yes the thirds the best right
yeah that guy's a wizard I bet Bryan
that God drives high every day yes so
he's used to it I'm not gonna show any
affect on his performance yeah it's the
experience is a novel experience and
right the if you're accustomed to it
then it's just like here we go this is
my normal world and for many people you
have to learn to get high you have to
learn to associate the subtle physical
cues with the altered state that's the
common thing people feel nothing the
first time they try it yeah you do hear
that right but I don't think they know
what the [ __ ] they're talking about your
eyes when you when you did these
experiments what did you have to clear
these with the f you would not believe
I'd have to do I had to get permission
from the FDA which said that I couldn't
do it unless I first got permission from
it was the old Federal Bureau of
Narcotics which was the Treasury guys
the federal bureaucratic said we'll give
you permission once the FDA gives you
permission so they played that off then
I had to get permission from the state
of Massachusetts from two agencies there
and there were two universities involved
Harvard University and Boston University
so coordinating all this stuff was
unbelievable and then once that all the
approvals came in I had to get the pot
and there was no legal source of it so I
Federal Bureau of Narcotics gave me
confiscated pot that they had
confiscated a case in Texas they brought
it over
they had delayed us so long I didn't
even know who that time to do the
experiments cuz I was going to graduate
anyway they brought this stuff on a
Friday afternoon
it was [ __ ] I mean it was brown dry it
looked like you've been sitting in a
warehouse for years right so the first
thing I did was roll up a joint and
smoke it no effect whatever I called the
the agent that I dealt with and I said
this stuff is no good he said how do you
know you haven't had time to run in the
experiment so I said I looked at it
under the microscope and there was no
resin on it so they grumbled and they
gave me other stuff which was passable
so but again confiscated stuff yeah
because we always used to hear when we
were kids about government we'd the
government we'd was the good weed I was
later that was later when that well when
research got going and the u.s. the
government started a pot farm in
Mississippi provide pot for research
which was much better and there was only
a handful of people that were under
these experiments correct so they made
it so difficult to conduct research as
they have with psychedelics now that's
slowly changing